matrices P * row plus 1 - P * Sigma this by the way is completely
analogous to what we would have if row and sigma weren't density matrices but rather were probability vectors
representing probabilistic States so this is not something shocking or mysterious but rather it's something
that perhaps is familiar from probability Theory we do this kind of averaging all the time when we're calculating probabilities and thinking
about classical random selections and the point is that this also works for density matrices but note that it does
not work for Quantum State vectors that is you can't generally average together two Quantum State
vectors like this and hope to get a valid Quantum State vector and if you try you'll usually get a vector that
doesn't have ukian Norm equal to one with density matrices however weighted averages like this will always
be valid density matrices and more importantly the density Matrix you get will represent that random selection in
a meaningful way this generalizes to random selections where there are more than two
Alternatives in particular if we have M possible density matrices and a probability Vector with M entries one
for each density Matrix and a system is prepared in each possible state with the corresponding probability
then the weighted average of those density matrices describes the resulting state of the system and by the way when
we refer to a convex combination of density matrices this is what we mean a convex combination is simply a linear
combination where the coefficients form a probability Vector this will always be a density
Matrix and a simple and concise way of saying that in mathematical terms is that the set of all density matrices
corresponding to a given system is a convex set so if we have say m Quantum State
vectors size 0 through S M minus one along with probabilities p 0 through p m minus one that collectively form a
probability vector and a system is prepared in the state s k with probability PK for each k then the
resulting state of the system is described by the density Matrix that's shown here on the screen in particular we're not averaging
together together the quantum State vectors themselves but rather we're averaging together the corresponding density
matrices in general a state like this will not have a representation as a single Quantum State
Vector unless something trivial is happening like all of the quantum State vectors are equivalent up to a global phase or all but one of the
probabilities are zero we will not obtain a pure Quantum state from such a process rather we'll obtain what's
called a mixed Quantum state where there's some inherent uncertainty involved let's take a look at a simple
example suppose that we have a cubit and with probability 1/2 the Cubit is prepared in the zero State and otherwise
it's prepared in the plus State here's the density Matrix that we get by averaging as I've
described we compute the density matrices corresponding to the two possible States multiply by the corresponding probabilities and add the
results what we get is indeed a den matrix it's heran it traces equal to one
and if you compute the igen values of this Matrix you will get two positive real numbers and they happen to be two numbers that should probably be familiar
to you by now cosine square of pi over 8 and sin square of pi over 8 or about 0.85 and
0.15 there is no single Quantum State Vector representation of the state it's not a pure state next we'll take a look at one
particular density Matrix that represents a Quantum state of a single Cubit known as the completely mixed
state the state arises frequently so it's good to have a name for it and it's also a good example because it
illustrates an important feature of density matrices there is in fact an analogously defined completely mixed state for any
system but for now we're going to focus on this state for a single Cubit just to keep things
simple suppose that we randomly set the state of a cubit to be either the zero State or the one state each with
probability equal to 1/2 much like a uniform random bit we can calculate the density Matrix representation of this
state in the usual way we take the average of the two density Matrix representations of the states here's how
that looks in Matrix form and what we obtain is the identity Matrix divided by
two this state is known as the completely mixed state and it basically represents complete or maximal
uncertainty about a cubit just like a uniform probability Vector represents maximal uncertainty in the
classical probabilistic setting in general for an arbitrary system the completely mixed state is the
state we obtain by uniformly choosing a standard basis State and the density Matrix representation will be the
identity Matrix divided by the dimension or equivalently the number of classical states of that
system at this point this is just terminology but if we change the setup a bit we'll see an important feature of
density matrices in particular let's suppose that we change the procedure and in
place of the zero and one standard basis States we substitute the plus and minus States this time we start with the
expression that's shown on the screen but if we go through the arithmetic we obtain exactly the same
density matrix it's the identity Matrix divided two so it's the same state as before the
complete the mixed state this as they say is a feature and not a bug the two procedures are in fact
different but if all you have is the resulting Cubit there is no physical way that you can possibly distinguish them
even in a statistical sense for example if you performed a standard basis measurement on this Cubit
after the first procedure was performed you would obviously get the outcome zero with probability 1/2 and the outcome one with probability 1/2 but you'd also get
exactly the same out probabilities for the second procedure and the same is true for any other test that you might
devise assuming that you're testing just the Cubit itself in general density matrices don't describe how a system was
prepared they only tell you what will happen if you do things to that system going forward whether that's performing
operations or measurements and in fact density matrices are perfect in this
regard if two different Alternatives result in the same density Matrix they cannot be discriminated even
statistically but if the two density matrices are different then there will be some way to discriminate them not
necessarily definitively but in a statistical sense when we use the general formulation of quantum